oh we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
i was going to talk to you guys today
about the so let me back up
a week ago i imagined that today i would
be talking to you about the us
anti-vaccine mandate trucker convoy
heading to washington dc set to arrive
today
their plan was to get to dc on the day
of joe biden's state of the union
address
a week ago i thought i'd be talking to
you about it i'm not because
nobody's paying attention to it and it's
not even clear that it seems to have
sort of disintegrated
and
one aspect of this is brought up in this
voicemail and our voicemail number again
is 2192 david p which is what mandates
are they protesting anyway take a listen
hi david listen i have a question for
you after all the mandates pretty much
been overturned and of course except for
you know by these federal ones in the
service and at the airports and stuff
everything else is pretty much been
overturned by the clerk am i wrong
so why are the complaints still for me
and still trying to make their way
across america now they got bikers doing
it too
and
they have much further cause why don't
they just take up their guns and go to
ukraine kyle written house to go with
him too he wanted to protect the
storefront let him protect the country
with their patriotism that trump calls
them all patriots but they're true
patriots that'll be something patriotic
even if it is for another country at
least it shows they got the ball yeah so
listen a couple thoughts on the u.s
trucker convoy first of all ima and i
tweeted about this yesterday and many of
you wrote back
absolutely loving it and saying you had
thought the same thing
imagine that you spend a month or six
weeks or however long it was
organizing this convoy of truckers that
wants to protest vaccine mandates and
government tyranny and authoritarianism
and you're going to drive across the
entire country i don't remember where
they started whether it was california
or arizona somewhere in the southwest or
maybe texas who the hell even knows
they're going to drive to washington d.c
and then
quite literally as they're about to
leave to start their convoy
russia invades ukraine and gets 24 7
coverage and no one pays attention to
your stupid convoy so like that's number
one
and that's funny and i genuinely take
pleasure in it that's hilarious nobody's
paying attention to these people because
russia has invaded ukraine but then
there are other layers of absurdity that
are
kafkaesque in this entire thing the
second one is the whole premise of the
trucker convoy
is that these are victims of tyranny and
authoritarianism right we are being
victimized by the tyrannical government
mostly state governments that say hey
you got to be vaccinated against kovid
and
quite literally russia invades ukraine
and people start dying and the president
of ukraine is out there fighting and you
as a trucker are trying to say i'm a
victim of tyranny when you see what's
going on in ukraine beyond parody okay
so that's like the second layer that's
that's funny or you know curious and
then of course the third one is what the
caller is saying
what mandates are you protesting so the
general biden vaccine mandate which by
the way wasn't a mandate because incur
it
include or allowed for a test out option
you can opt out and test instead
um that was blocked by a court
you then have states and municipalities
that have various vaccine requirements
you got to be vaccinated to work in a
healthcare setting or you've got to show
a vaccine card to go to a restaurant or
whatever they're mostly dropping it
because why it was an imaginary slippery
slope all along as covid is waning for
now fortunately and who knows what the
future holds variance spikes resurgence
cases are down 95
and exactly as the same people expected
as the threat from covet goes down
various requirements are being
eliminated there's barely any mask
requirements left yes you've got to wear
masks on airplanes uh there's some some
cities and places that but the mask
requirements are going away the vaccine
requirements are going it's all going
away so what are you even protesting at
this point it's really an example this
entire u.s the canadian convoy was this
but the u.s trucker convoy is even more
so this
what are you protesting at this point
what on earth are you protesting and
they're just desperate for attention
which they're not getting thankfully
not thankfully that russia invaded
ukraine but thankfully as a result of
there being real news in the world
nobody's paying attention to that stupid
convoy and i'm absolutely loving every
minute of it we have a fantastic bonus
show for you today first of all
what would it look like
if ukraine joined the european union how
would it work what would it look like
and
what would be putin's reaction we're
going to talk about ukraine and the eu
on today's bonus show secondly
hackers
have been very involved in the russian
invasion of ukraine taking down a number
of prominent russian websites
uh and doing a whole bunch of other
stuff and one of the recent things that
happened is that 120 000 russian
soldiers have been doxed by hackers
meaning that their identities and their
personal information has been released
and
we're going to talk about obviously
that is is not in the realm of what we
typically consider cyber warfare
but where does that type of thing fit in
in uh international military conflicts
there are differing opinions it might
sound like no no no here's the here's
the one view on doxing soldiers and its
validity but there are actually some
dissenting views on that we're going to
talk about that and then number three
yesterday i told you that fifa has
determined russia
uh russian players can play in the world
cup but no russian national anthem and
they can't be identified as russia
that's been canceled russia has now been
totally thrown out of the world cup fifa
has decided they're just it's just a
hard no
and we're going to talk about that and
other
kind of sports related sanctions that
have come in the past and that may come
in the future all of those stories and
more are on two days bonus show how do
you get access to the bonus show simple
sign up for a membership at
joinpacman.com you can use the coupon
code please don't war i know it sounds
ungrammatical but that's what it is the
coupon code is please don't war you'll
get a discount off of a membership
you'll get access to the bonus show the
commercial free audio feed the
commercial free video feed and much much
more we will see you then and tonight
live
on youtube twitch and facebook for joe
biden's state of the union address i
hope you'll join me i will see you then